[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're doing it we're back whoa
good to see you man you too you look
good
oh thank you i got i got eight hours of
sleep last night which is so rare for me
i got like six and a half which is
honestly i'll take it six and a half
isn't bad it's not a horrible number no
because you're in you're you're going
towards seven yeah that's pretty good it
wasn't hard but of course i got
a year of construction in my building
just
and you can't talk [ __ ] cause you got
the hammer yeah right right where are
you at on sleep mask would you do that i
do it you do it at home yeah you don't
no
it's nice i got drapes yeah and they
match the carpet
but uh wow what's wrong with it i don't
know i mean nothing drove i just i just
want to wake up and wake up i don't want
to i got the tempurpedic so it like it
almost like puts pressure on the eyelids
it's kind of nice i like it
yeah that's pretty good yeah what about
a fan all my friends going up i gotta
have a fan going that's like a lady
thing i feel like oh the fan because
they always want it to be a little
colder in the sound right right yeah
women are always cold but they also want
it to be cold that's true
yeah that's true it's uh remember that
great david tell joke he's like you know
why women like a vibrator sounds like
it's listening
[Laughter]
damn
god damn i know he's the king how do you
find that angle i know exactly i've
heard 800 vibrator jokes never heard
that that's a clean vibrator yes that's
right that's why it's oh man well uh
yeah i like the noise machine it was
raining gently last night i know which
is like oh my god i think that helps
that's new the absolute best yeah cause
it's funny if you go on youtube there's
all these like sleep
four hour sleep sound you know it's like
rain or waves or whatever
for me it's i they need to make a new
york one it's just hobo lady yelling
guy screaming you know deranged guy
talking about the government or whatever
there's the black israelite like you
need to listen i'm like this is
beautiful
yeah exactly
the jews it's like a farrakhan thing
yeah i was in utah all weekend and i'll
tell you man every downtown is crazy
right i know it is like
drugs i mean meth people losing their
jobs but like it's crazy because vitor
and i were like this is like a video
game yeah we're walking by and we'd see
a guy i'm like this guy looks like a
boss you know he's like walking toward
you like [ __ ] it's like holding a knife
we're just i'm like all right you go
right you go left everyone in utah is
either uh is either that or like hi i'm
brother gary how are you there's no
middle ground no well i feel like the
middle and utah are these people who
they have neck tattoo right they're
ripped they all look like ex-ufc
fighters and all the women there look
like old porn stars they got fake tits
and lips that's true there there's a big
milf community oh
yeah the real housewives of salt lake
that's right yeah they also have kids
well because they all got the husbands
wouldn't [ __ ] them in their early 20s
unless they were married so they got
married at like 22 right and now they're
single again at 40. yeah and they're
horny as [ __ ] cause they haven't [ __ ]
their husband in five years yeah and
they don't drink because they're all
mormon oh they're all oh my god that
looks creamy dude that looks like
thousand island dressing what the hell
is that penne vodka
no
that's our fully loaded bloody mary
today what is it loaded with oh we got
everything in there we got the
traditional stuff horseradish uh
worcestershire some some pepper salt
with the tajin rim
and then we got a cornish shown and
stuffed olives on top i love a corner
uh you know the uh obligatory celery
stick yep a little lemon juice some
tabasco and for an extra kick of spice i
added some uh red-eyed chilies in there
i'm not gonna lie to you it's the best
bloody mary i've ever had wow
well thank you for that that is
phenomenal i've had a lot of these at
airports let me see what's what
i really hope i don't lose out the
airport
wow that's damn good came in second of
the united lounge
well after 9 11 i had one
celebration this is really good mmm
that's crazy that is amazing and it's
just spicy enough not too much you gotta
make one for peters who a producer who's
apparently never had
a bloody how has you've never had a
bloody mary well peters hates vegetables
let's be honest
we'll pop his tomato it's fine look how
much work he put into that i'm not doing
that what someone ordered you can order
it oh okay
are you like a are you a kill a hangover
with a beer guy is that what it is
i've only had like two hangovers oh get
out of here with that
i'm really upset
sorry i'll leave i feel like i had two
hangovers this week uh no this is uh
this is great i love a bloody mary over
mimosa those are like the brunch options
i think but bloody mary you could order
in like a [ __ ] hole that's why i like
ordering mimosa in a dive bar good point
good and also it's i think you go for
the bloody mary for the savory over
sweet if you're like an eggs over
pancakes for breakfast which i am yes
this is the hetero mimosa exactly
has a great joke about like there's this
guy who sent back a mimosa on a friday
night in a dive bar and i knew i could
kill him but then he sent it back and i
knew he was an assassin so you know i
just like who would order you know like
a brunch drink out of that dive bar yeah
like confidently so like you know what i
just finished my bloody mary and i got
the [ __ ] out of there like
it's like leo ordering a cranberry juice
yeah departed remember that woody on
your period
great scene i just watched a four-hour
martin scorsese
breakdown it was amazing what is it it's
just on youtube i i just get sucked into
these it just starts his whole career to
the the final movie he did
what's his last movie
uh
oh jeez he did hugo hugo was good then
he did
wolf of wall street great i love that
love that yeah i can't remember now but
he's got all these other ones that we
haven't heard he did a bob dylan biopic
right i didn't see that
what's the last one
oh [ __ ] oh oh irishman oh yeah that was
it was solid solid too long
they really spend way too much money on
that anti-aging stuff i mean de niro's
body it's like oh
you saw him kicking the guy and i'm like
this looks more painful for you yes
that was i've seen the the jesse
smallett fight look more real than that
[ __ ] thing
yeah that was bad the last i mean you
know who's amazing in that movie though
is pesci it's like oh yeah because it's
a treat to just see pesci show up at
this point so true and it had all the
usual suspects it was deniro pesci
harvey keitel yes uh it was great great
time
kind of underrated man i agree always
brings it always decent hog too
big dick bad lieutenant you see a hog
yeah i've got i you know it's funny i
was just going down like a youtube
rabbit hole on the road and i was
watching nicholas cage bad lieutenant
scenes oh yeah you were seeing that in
the theater and just being like what the
[ __ ] is this
it's pretty funny it's funny yeah cage
is fun
yeah he goes for it he's got that new
movie out where he um looks good yeah
look he's just like making fun of
himself it's it's like a meta kind of
play on himself it's all only he could
really do something yeah it looks it
looks really good oh yeah and the fact
that he's got these gambling debts so he
has to do ghost rider too i i find
endearing
it's like he's like the norm of movies
yes yes exactly and he's good too on top
of it so you get he's so good he's
almost too good for a certain move you
can always tell when he knows he's in a
stinker because he just like overdoes it
and he's like if if i'm going down i'm
going down like a [ __ ] g yes like
kane or face off is so hilariously over
the top even the the national treasures
they've made a couple of those those are
still are they good no i mean they're
fun they're like uh disney horseshit you
know it's a fun action family movie
adaptation's incredible incredible
that's one of the best performances that
at least leaving las vegas yeah yeah
yeah that's it that's a downer though oh
yeah but like family man family man is
solid is it i think it's solid i think
it's a solid holiday like is it cheesy
absolutely but it's like he's amazing in
it okay okay
he plays like the miserable rich guy who
like it's like what's what's a movie
that it's kind of
a remake of hmm
he's also in a movie called the weather
man which i thought was underrated yeah
it was dark yeah yeah it was pretty good
i used to work at blockbuster so i'd see
all these box i could see the boxes in
my head that was a great box
[Music]
[Laughter]
so yeah utah huh
yeah utah's all right though where were
you you in dc right i was all over
listen to this run i did
pittsburgh university oh yeah how was
that great this guy this guy russ who
put the whole thing on as a genius
because he took the the show took it out
of the university and put it at the
improv so all the college kids came to
the improv your turf my turf
different rules
he's like say anything you want he was
like they were nervous about your
content they watched your special
and they had some some doubts they
didn't want to have you so i said what
if we move them off campus they said
great wow it worked out yeah yeah so hot
show
great a good room you ever been there
yeah yeah good road a good layout i buy
those abandoned uh trail tracks yeah
rail tracks rather yeah yeah it's like a
steam
uh what do you call that uh steel town
you know it's all those steel mines
pittsburgh is cool cool i've had good
times i mean we've got the warhol museum
yeah yeah the uh
got some cool restaurants downtown it's
kind of a pretty city too i heard that
ballpark is legendary beautiful and you
fly over it's almost like chicago it's
just like the the river with the bridges
going through it's great yeah pittsburgh
is cool so that was great got out of
there and went to charlottesville
did the southern you should do this room
yeah killer i would but the jews can't
replace you
[Laughter]
it was good yeah small like black box
like 200 seats i've done it oh you did
it i've done it before yeah yeah great
room with fat crystal and we we uh we
hit that up and then we did durham the
carolina theater so i rented a car drove
to durham and then flew to dc the next
day and did the lincoln highlight of my
life beautiful theater it looked
beautiful
chris rock special
killing softly's there and uh bill birds
why do i do this is all wow
classics classics and uh just uh it hits
you i'm backstage with chris allen like
what the [ __ ] are we doing that imposter
syndrome
oh my god come on when you when you go
from the pittsburgh improv to the
lincoln theater it's like
who am i what is this you know oh dude
you're putting in work you know it's
it's it's payoff for the work you've
been putting in it's nice payoff yeah so
we had then the beauty of it though you
try to enjoy it i'm trying
because
i feel it too the imposter syndrome yeah
but at the same time you know
you gotta when you have these milestones
you gotta feel it you gotta feel it yeah
so of course
you're right you gotta be gracious so i
put up a cheesy instagram post because i
was just beaming about the whole time
yeah yeah and then here's the here's
where the psycho kicks in we do the uh
lincoln theater sean joyce goes i got a
brand new club
it's 110 seats you want to come do it i
go i'm on my way yeah we go to the place
called the hotbed
and uh just do [ __ ] sets i saw the
comedy artwork guy post a picture of it
was of you but with a mustache and fake
glasses on like a bad disguise i was
like is i is this supposed to be
yeah but it wasn't you know yeah yeah
but it was all your it was all your
people though yeah the problem was some
of the lincoln people came out to like
oh we're gonna go to the secret show too
and so i'm like that's a lot of the same
stuff you know yeah well it is the same
stuff right yeah yeah i mean i tried
some new one there just because i felt
guilty but uh we all had a great time
and
you know i mean we're club guys like
these theaters are great but it's just
fun to sit in the back of a club and
[ __ ] it's a different type of show
yeah you have to kind of pace it a
little differently
uh exactly it's less [ __ ] around
riffing and stuff but uh you know i did
a sunday we had a sunday on on easter
and it sold out in salt lake which was
pretty cool yeah oh man talk about some
heathens man really i mean hey you're
out on easter and salt lake
these are my people yes yes that's such
a great club great room keith is great
keith is great i love that place and the
nba playoffs are on it's like i have the
game on the back and you know and then
you go on it's perfect hell yeah yeah i
feel like a club is like a diner we feel
very comfortable in a diner and then the
theater is like a steak white tablecloth
you know so you're like this is nice but
i don't know if i fit in yeah that's a
good point mm-hmm
but i love a diner love a diner
you can do it diners always feel good
like there's so much you can order yes
there's so much you could do in a diner
right right the menu is this big with
eight million options it's like porn
porn used to be missionary harry bush
and uh
[Music]
uh what's that guy's name ron jeremy and
now
porn is like
adopted trans-immigrant uh does
cartwheel on to dick or whatever i'm
like do you have not adopted i want a
nuclear family here
uh
no it's uh yeah and ron jeremy's on
trial for rape
i mean that's [ __ ] that's wild like
you didn't get laid enough you fat
[ __ ] pig
you didn't you didn't [ __ ] enough above
your weight yeah no pun intended yeah
it's hard to get above it yeah yeah the
hedgehog that's what they called him
yeah yeah just the ugliest guy i think
he gave hope to a lot of a lot of sad
dudes out there i don't think i don't
think sonic ever uh grabbed a woman at
the tails hold her down
well he was fast
[Laughter]
yeah look at this i mean he looks like a
villain too he's so scary remember one
night you're on at the cellar i went on
after you and he was asleep in the crowd
and you just turn to your right and you
go is ron jeremy [ __ ] asleep and i
got a huge blast oh man that's great oh
my god look at him
he looks like he looks like rape santa
doesn't he look at that [ __ ] that's the
worst cologne by the way
you don't want to spray that on
holy [ __ ] wow there is his mario he's
coming at you geez scary guy well
salaccus will be missed
that's every comment about salgi's ron
jerry run jeremy right wow i i never
would have seen that that would be
hilarious yeah we can get a side by side
that would be exciting but i don't want
to call maybe we can call salaku's rape
santa rape santa's good
[Laughter]
the holidays damn what a weird
great is that is that him that's sally
look at that oh he looks good he looks
good there
looks sharp yeah that's back in his back
in the 70s salacious was still
24. he still wore hawaiian shirts he's
still blowing lines yeah
damn yeah you know what
come on you can see it a little that's
sad when ron jeremy's looking a little
better
well that's very young
yeah
weird to just get into porn when you
look like that yeah when you're like you
look in the mirror and you're like yeah
porn star right yeah why not i guess so
i mean stallone tried porn what you
didn't know this no there's footage he's
in a porno uh he couldn't make any money
he couldn't get a gig in la he was broke
and he did a couple pornos damn yeah
there he is
come on it was before he started lifting
weights too yeah yo adrian hey nice
piece not bad no you're gonna have to
blur that
yeah you gotta blur wow
big bush too jesus big bush bush senior
holy hell
good time all right all right what are
we doing this is it's turning me on this
is awful
can i give you a peeve please peters you
know what it's going to be pull it up
pull it up
you know
that your boy yeah look at that i'm on a
flight yesterday i'm one away from full
flight i'm hoping to get that first
class upgrade i'm one away
yeah i'm not i'm in delta comfort but
not bad this [ __ ]
look at that i i know people commenting
like what's his middle seat he's allowed
to have the have the arm bar hey i'm
fine with that the arm rest
my issue is when the arm starts leaking
into my area yes that elbow now look at
me i'm bunched up
totally yeah now this is crazy and you
you're a tall guy so you got a wingspan
so now you're doing the the arm clasp i
am which i hate because it gets your
armpit hot and it's just you can't fall
asleep like this
yeah it's crazy it wasn't good yeah oh
and also of course you know i'm on three
hours sleep
i'm trying to fall asleep and you get
the
shout out to the flight attendants i
know it's a tough job you get them
walking by and they're just like granola
cookies pretzels almonds but granola i'm
like they all you have to say it again
ever you don't have to reset every
second exactly and that
you try to wave over to the other side
just to even out a little bit and then
they hit you with the cart oh yeah it
never end then the announcements keep
going too they were very nice though but
but they did i wasn't able to sleep
because of that but you know what i also
was like it's my fault for not sleeping
so what are you gonna do well what is
that that's a four and a half hour
flight too that's no joke that's it's
always longer than you that when you
remember always utah i mean that's west
this is leaning into the
this is it's an invasion
that is it's an invasion of space
invasion of normandy or maril mindy but
yeah it's crazy terrible that is too
much see what you got to do is every now
and then just kind of do one of these
and then you hit his elbow and then
maybe he'll realize like oh i'm i'm deep
into this territory he's crossing the
border
he didn't do it for long he went back
pretty quickly i kind of okay because
what you do is he comes up for a sec i
slid right in yes so that way it's like
a non-confrontational go [ __ ] yourself
right he lifts i go oh i'm sorry that's
the move and i just kind of turned to
him gently
and then started eating seaweed snacks
like this
and breathing it on them oh
smelly
those are the grossest things to eat
next to someone on a flight totally just
you go
there's that little crunch and the
crackle yeah my lady eats those all day
there's little seaweed drops all over
the
place
they taste great you smell like [ __ ]
afterwards
yeah now top to bottom both smell like
seaweed all right everybody come on
what do you got
here's a peeve that i had this one on
the road you ever get the guy who asks
you a question and answers it yeah you
know like the uh he's like what do you
want for dinner uh you know the guy
coming in about the show he's like we
got a lot of great restaurants around
here i'm like yeah i'm hungry
let's see what am i going to eat he goes
what kind of food you want italian
i'm like no let me take let me think let
me think maybe i'll do something asian
tai i'm like let me answer he's asking
me the question and then answering it
he's trying to get to the answer before
i can say it and it's throwing me off
yeah he's like what are you drinking i'm
like he's like beer
let me answer yeah it's like the game
show of his life here yes what what i
mean yeah it doesn't help sometimes i
don't mind when someone does it if it's
like if it's like a friend i'm with and
they i just i'm like i can't decide i'm
so bad at deciding what to eat yeah i
always feel like i [ __ ] up the second
i do it me too
i don't i don't want someone
deciding the meal no you agree on the
meal you suggest yes and then i couldn't
figure out why it annoyed me so much
it's because you have to keep saying no
and i feel guilty you know he's like you
want to tell him i'm like nah not really
and he you can tell he's like oh geez
i've been throwing out 18 suggestions
and i'm like well i'll get it you just
got to give me a second you're like
you're like a woman at a frat party like
no
no
no i know i'm talking to ron jeremy here
he's like do you want [ __ ] you're like
no not [ __ ]
penis how about penis how about balls no
i'm good but yeah my parents do a thing
and tell me if yours do where they'll go
like
they'll go uh hey so i heard you uh you
auditioned for that
movie
did you get it
and i'm like that movie was six months
ago and if i would have gotten it i'd be
i would lead with that so now i have to
go no i didn't get it and now i feel
like a douche
even though they're trying to be nice
and and remember the [ __ ] but i'm
telling them no and uh the whole thing
is you booked the movie yeah if i booked
a movie i would have texted you mom
you know a month ago i wouldn't be like
i'll sit on that until we're completely
out of stuff to say and let you bring it
up yeah i know i'm terrible that i mean
i i my parents do that all the time and
i'm like what happened with that
with that [ __ ] with that movie uh they
went with someone else a year and a half
ago yeah yeah we just saw the movie at
the theater mom i wasn't in it
yeah but i get there trying but it's
brutal
yeah i think you just start forgetting
[ __ ] yeah i think you ever just feel
that way you ever just like you were
just like did i do that and then i was
like yeah i think that's like is that
that we're run down and tired from bad
sleep schedules or are we slowly
declining mentally i wonder that too
well i'm noticing
that friends of ours are repeating
stories that they've told us already and
i'm like dude you're like 37.
why are we in repeats we got our whole
lives ahead of us let's go make some
memories why are we talking about the
thing that's already happened again
right it's a little much
and i think people just have go-to stuff
that they're like oh you said this i'll
i got this
but i'm like i already heard that story
and do i keep do i react like i haven't
heard it yeah you're rude if you're just
like we've there's a rerun here exactly
is that rude i don't know call in
that's tough
i'll tell you what's not tough this bm i
know can i get another one of these yeah
i think
i'll do one more too uh it is for you by
the way the comments are going to be
you've said you both said this
four to seven times you're right
i had that once the peeve has been uh
repeat yeah no
[Music]
so i mean you were all over the place
man oh yeah too good this is too good a
problem it really is this is the
ultimate hangover are you making the
spicy oh absolutely i mean i feel a kick
yeah i mean like you can use a little
tabasco if you don't like spice or you
could add like something a little hotter
i like to add a little like uh pepper
not like jalapenos but like some uh like
red-eyed chilis um ones that like will
just give you that like kind of like
bite your tongue but not like too much
perfect flavor but you can go like
habanero if you want that's for the [ __ ]
if you really want to get crazy and have
a lot of cool flavor you can find like
nice fresh ones scotch bottle peppers
yep oh my god how do you feel with the
places that go crazy and they put like
bacon and shrimp okay so here we go so
like i was thinking about like putting
shrimp in here or something like that
and like just eating our drink today but
the thing about bacon shrimp absolutely
that totally makes sense but like bacon
it looks nice it's cool but then you get
soggy bacon unless it's perched like
nicely on top and then a greasy drink
and the last thing that you want a
bloody mary to be is greasy like there's
those places that will put like a slider
on top and then eventually like as it
comes to your rotisserie chicken right
here
yeah
you know i think that you can go crazy
with like you can get some like pearl
onions any kind of like you know pickled
anything pickled yes really well and no
bloody absolutely new orleans we're big
shrimp okra okra oprah is fantastic that
sounds amazing oh yeah because it dips
in too it's a long veggie so okay okay
absolutely
that's a little harder to find in new
york though
is it not really but you have to go to
like a specialty store like find it in
like the like weirdo pickled aisle or
whatever like
by the way that's a wreck for anybody
pickled anything get pickled everything
is fantastic pickled garlic pickles
onions i want to throw a pickled
watermelon out there we really know
that's not a big thing but it's amazing
sounds good pickled watermelon is great
it's spicy but has that like tang to it
and the texture changes it's really
really good watermelon is more versatile
than we give a credit for i mean the
italians do the watermelon and feta
right that's right that's right you can
do you can grill a watermelon and you
know a lot of the vegan community says
that it
has the texture of steak i don't know i
haven't tried that
they're getting carried away yeah yeah
exactly it's it's look i love watermelon
it's not i'll give you like mushroom is
not a bad for a sandwich sure sure
but it's like when people say
the butthole feels just like [ __ ] like
no it doesn't come on
we all know you're full of [ __ ] no pun
intended no it's uh
they're getting carried away in that
community yeah i don't mind that seitan
though it tastes pretty good the what
the the seitan you know it's like the
they do like thai places will do mock
duck with it tastes pretty good that's
pretty good yeah yeah uh you know what
else is versatile and andy haynes has a
great bit about it but um
uh cauliflower it's like cauliflower
crust cauliflower um
buffalo cauliflower there's all these
cauliflower houses i think i've heard
this it's just something like uh hey
it's cauliflower's agent it's like hey
man i know we've been on ice for a while
but i got you back in every day
it's gonna be a good year that's great
that's a great joke yeah i love jokes
where you take some silly thing and make
it another thing we've been on ice for a
year and we're back
that's so silly cause when you're a kid
cauliflower was like i don't want that
mom and now it's just everything
you know what i just watched that's not
good have you seen batman the new one i
watched half of it was so slow to make
it's not good i didn't love it that's
not a good movie and i hate how
dark it is and he's so moody and [ __ ]
like yeah i'm out yeah it's like they
were twisting it that i was like all
right i mean like you just don't care no
you don't care that's what it is nolan i
care i'm in i cared a lot
yeah it's tough to you know i think part
of the problem was i think the the other
ones
it's hard to start a superhero franchise
without showing part of the origin story
we just come in like mid batman yeah you
gotta you gotta reboot the origin story
and do it differently totally totally
even like the penguin guy i don't wanna
give too much away but i was like he's
not very penguiny he
now that's a penguin i want the
cigarette on the stick i want some
flappers you know a top hat at least
same with catwoman she wasn't very cat
like nah she had like one cat and she
just like pet it i'm like this is you
have one cat in nails right right
exactly michelle pfeiffer like fell out
a window and got like raped by an alley
of cats that's that's catwoman yes here
here we just sound old and she had she
at least licked him she went she would
lick her paw i mean we're talking cat
stuff here i think they were nervous
because the halle berry one was such a
bomb
then i almost like almost forgot they
made that but uh
dude yeah i just kind of didn't care and
like the actors were all really good and
it looked beautiful and the score was
like you know what it felt like
it felt like
like a stripper
in tampa where you're like well you look
great but i don't want to spend three
hours with you ooh
you nailed it that's perfect that's
perfect yeah i think you're right i was
kind of i i'm not even like a big
superhero movie guy but i was kind of
like eh it's got good reviews let me let
me throw it on and if i'm on my phone
within 20 minutes yeah that's a bad sign
for a batman action adventure movie i'm
on my phone get out of it the action was
pretty good but yeah but the story i
just in the script i just didn't give a
[ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] i'm with you
i'll tell you what's amazing this is my
wreck for the week we're talking movies
worst person in the world i heard it's
amazing holy holy [ __ ] it is next level
it's i think it's norwegian there it is
the girl in it is amazing i should have
watched that what was i thinking it's
incredible i mean it's subtitled and all
that but you don't
five minutes in you don't even notice
you're so wrapped in it it's a just a
whole character piece it's all about her
and her
her wishes and desires and how twisted
she is and all that it's [ __ ] great
it also shows like they don't have all
the american [ __ ] where they have to
have we need eight people in a
wheelchair for this to get made you know
it's just like a good movie with a good
script
uh and it's it's a little slow but it's
good slow like you are in it it's like a
bark lounger i have one person described
it to me as a woody allen movie without
the guilt
is that accurate that's perfect yeah so
true so very woody allen and the other
uh summary i got was it's hard to pin it
in to a genre
like it kind of
it fits in a lot of different things it
yeah that's good it's like a it's kind
of rom-e but not really kami
but then it's not like cheesy and mushy
either so yeah that's a good good
description i can't wait till i'm gonna
watch it this week all right now these
are a little redder
the period is hitting a heavier flow
all right well you gotta get peter's one
don't worry i have more okay just
checking peters you gotta try this
look at that
it's like a
a garden of
many assorted veggies here you give me
an extra uh little mini pickle oh yeah
thank you buddy thank you i love these
mini pickles second one's even better
yeah
fantastic is that what those are called
cornish that is stupid
dude this is the best drink this is the
best bloody mary i've ever had it's
incredible and i love a good bloody mary
oh yeah what is that what's the tequila
it's my ex
that's the last one
you ever have a bloody bowl
yes actually what the hell's that that
is some crazy [ __ ] that's good i was
introduced that by like old school
steakhouse bartenders that is a wild
drink what's a bloody bird it's a bloody
mary but with beef broth right is that
yes it literally just has beef broth
it's really good it's in it's good it's
just intense it's definitely not for
everyone but it's it's that's a you know
how you say like bloody mary's you drink
you eat your drink yes
that you're you've got to eat that [ __ ]
with a spoon that's a hangover cure
right there though bloody bowl you get
that and you get a burger and you're and
you're in business oh yeah you're in
good shape well you're you're taking a
nap that's what you're doing yeah holy
moly bloody bold bloody bowls are
intense actually another another great
garnish for
oh it's got a [ __ ] beef bloody mary's
in general is a nice like smoked sausage
oh there it is yeah
yeah yeah exactly
okra
okra yeah exactly cheese yeah meat i
don't know about the cheese but like the
the meat part is definitely like a nice
really heavy smoked sausages on there
fantastic yeah i feel like a bloody mary
you never would do this but it would
just go well with a steak oh yeah but i
feel like people always order like
scotch or wine what's good something
with the steak you never order a bloody
mary with a steak good but now here's
the question do you like v8 on its own
yeah dude me too i'll order tomato juice
in the sky apparently it i don't know
why
i've researched this before and i and
for some reason i just i keep forgetting
this but there's a reason why tomato
juice tastes better in elevation uh
because i'll tell you a tomato juice or
a bloody mary in the sky oh yeah that's
a [ __ ] nice that's a good drink to
get a little buzzed on definitely and i
think maybe we want the salt because
there's a lot of sodium in tomato juice
so maybe there's some kind of
it's up in the air you're depleted who
the hell knows but yeah give me that
salt i guess it dehydrates a little more
too like i'm not not yourself but like
the juice itself so it's like a little
like almost chunkier yeah oh there you
go
you're less sensitive to taste in the
out in altitude
so you need something with some real
kick
hmm
there you go
yeah it's really good uh that's what's
your go-to if you're going to get drunk
on a flight what is
a good question i usually go uh
whiskey water
really or like whiskey soda i mean
whiskey and club soda that's a good one
yeah it's just light it goes down easy
it's bubbly
um it's got a good flavor
yeah because if i do tequila soda or
vodka soda i'll have too many i i need
the kick of the whiskey to remind me
like hey this is this is booze man don't
have too many of these
it is helpful to feel that's why it's
like man
when you don't it's like edibles that's
why you get way too [ __ ] up about you
know yes
or boy stove got
way too [ __ ] up on an edible to the
point that he almost missed his flight
back oh no
i mean he basically did miss his flight
back but he uh but he made it back still
yeah i've done edibles once on a flight
on accident i was with chris redd in
ireland we did the dublin fest and he
was like hey take one of these for your
flight i'm like i'm a lightweight he's
like this is nothing was that when i was
there with you
yes yeah saying with chris red we took a
ride to the airport together
and i was hungover he's like this will
make you feel better and it was a chewy
thing and i popped it and i was high out
of my mind that's like a six hour flight
i didn't [ __ ] blink for six hours i
was like who's that guy who's she do
they know they all know ah this kid next
to me he's a narc i'm going down that
tsa is gonna tackle me and tase me i'm
gonna get that asian guy thing where
they pulled the guy off the united
flight
remember that guy
so i was just panicking you just picture
one of the
the flight attendants putting
chlorophyll over your mouth
yeah yeah exactly
yeah dude i i can't do it i can't do the
edibles i hate it i really don't like
being high i don't like it no no i like
alcohol i like to take the the feelings
and just push them right down same i
don't want to bring them to light i want
to i want to choke them out here here
i'm with you and people do it people
feel better they smoke weed they're like
i'm i'm uh i'm right as rain like i
finally feel leveled out and like good
more power to you but i'm a mess it is
funny than the old school movies that
doing that like just drinking yourself
like until you didn't feel because that
was the whole thing back in the day was
like the strong silent type yeah now
it's almost like you get street cred by
having mental illness
yeah you know it's like i've always said
like comics having mental illness is
like a can uh a rapper's
like the times they've been shot or
something right you know but like back
in the day you watch an old bogey movie
and he's like you know casablanca he's
just downing booze and he's like he's
like play it sam if he can take it so
can i just bound in a bottle of whiskey
and that was like manly you know right
it's so true though because i think
struggle is cool like i came from the
projects or right or i'm from this
[ __ ] crazy nation and i escaped or
the holocaust i flew to america you're
like whoa that's crazy and if we're just
whitey who grew up in the suburbs we're
like well i have uh
i'm bipolar or i'm depressed or i'm
autistic or whatever it is so we need
that's our that's our thing
because you know we we didn't we didn't
get bullets whizzing over our heads
we had a soccer practice we had an
orange slice and a lunch box so we need
some kind of struggle yeah and we have
the course your own what are they called
yeah that's when i start calling my
flaccid dick
it's time baby it's cornish
[Laughter]
yeah it sounds nice that sounds fancy
and then they get there like oh you
meant
forget it jake it's cornichon
but that's the thing is like back in the
day you had those problems i mean they
were manic depressives and all that [ __ ]
but you just you just kept it in but i
feel bad for like an old man is
depressive who was like yeah it was just
people were just annoyed by it totally
totally like sinatra was a manic
depressive you know really yeah
undiagnosed but yeah i think he was a
manic depressive and like people were
just like he's just an [ __ ] which
like i'm sure he was on top of it sure
but
he had other [ __ ] he had some real beef
with like young people like elvis he was
like oh [ __ ] that guy and then elvis got
big enough and they had they met on the
ed sullivan show and it was a big deal
but it was like worlds colliding damn
there was a lot of young and old like i
wear a suit he's shaking his ass out
there with the long hair [ __ ] these
hippies it's well basically just comes
down to [ __ ] this guy he's different
than me pretty much which is kind of
lame yeah i think so and it's this east
coast italian versus this like sexy
southerner you know right the worlds are
colliding where is he where's elvis
memphis memphis yeah
hugh another another hog nice piece take
a put google in
a lot of editing work for matt this week
bulger matt how are you spending your
friday uh editing editing famous cox
well you don't see it it's not exposed
but it's quite a bulge he's sitting on a
porch drinking an iced tea and it's like
it's appalling his name is his dick
looks like iced tea
i guess because you never see him so
when you see a imprint you're like all
right noted
but also there's a great video of elvis
backstage and he walks out of a green
room and goes
that lady gives him good head
and then he goes on stage yeah
because i can't imagine the amount of uh
women just lined up to blow this guy it
must be the most famous guy on the
planet like i just read the lakers
showtime book and the amount of ass that
all the lakers in the 80s got like think
picture
los angeles in the 80s oh my god coke
was king matt there's a great story
about magic johnson uh he loans his car
to a friend
and the friend said the car lit on fire
it blew up and magic on the phone isn't
even mad he's just like did you save a
number in the glove compartment
because that's how much ass yeah he got
he was like [ __ ] there's ass right in
the car i mean the amount of the the
amount of
the amount of [ __ ] that these lakers
got yeah it's like comic i'm sure it
didn't slow down surely odds i'm sure
like you know but
it's crazy i was at a i did a gig in
portland i was staying in a nice hotel
i was with all the whatever team was
playing the trailblazers and i was in an
elevator with like eight hookers
and they were all going up to the suite
to meet the i don't know who it was the
phoenix suns or whatever it was but
they were all 11s they were all taller
than me they were all cleavaged out and
everything and they were so excited to
go [ __ ] these basketball players that's
awesome it was awesome everybody wins
they get laid they get laid everyone's
happy yeah dude i mean the story was
james worthy who was like came from like
the you know lakers star in the 80s
early 90s and came from this religious
background and then a story broke that
in portland he was soliciting
prostitutes and it turned out you know
it was just cops
so he got busted and it was a big news
story and he was married so everyone's
like if the good guy is doing this right
what are the bad dudes on the team doing
so it was you know bad press but it's
like that's just the time it was you
know well where are you at on
prostitutes like i i it's not i i don't
you don't like it no really i mean not
saying what i'm saying how do you feel
about it oh i think it's your body you
should do whatever the hell you want but
for me i would just like i regret
consensual regular sex
so like why like i'm gonna i'm gonna pay
for it too right right but they need
they need the money maybe
they're they're they're into it maybe
yeah it doesn't mean i have to give it
to them sure there's charities but i
think some people if you go hey that guy
gets a lot of [ __ ] they go hey that's
[ __ ] that guy he's a weirdo but you're
like i think
whatever do whatever you want it's not
i'm not no judgment yeah yeah same how
about you i feel the same way i think i
think it eventually will be legal well
it is legal in a lot of states is it
it's i mean isn't sex work illegal and i
think it's legal nevada i think it's
illegal
i mean if you can put drugs in your
system i've always kind of been the
opinion like
it's your body yeah i mean it's
i agree i think if i was a parent i
would feel differently probably you know
like like the grooming [ __ ] is what is
wow yeah it's [ __ ] up to me it's like
when it's like when they start super
young but you know sure no i'm with you
there you go only place is allowed in is
in nevada
well yeah they had that so they had that
cat ranch show remember oh yeah remember
that dude he was at one of my shows once
bunny ranch yeah what was his name again
the guy yeah he seemed like a cool fun
guy he wasn't
to me at least oh okay i remember this
must have been okay
yeah what's a guy's name yeah he's i
think there's a documentary on this you
know what he was he was like the dude in
big lebowski where you're like that guy
draws a lot of water in this town
that was his energy of like uh dennis
yeah i met him all right i was opening
for jim florentine in like 2010 class
wow and uh florentine is awesome he's a
nice guy
and uh and he was at the show
and
he came in the green room with like
these hot women yeah and
he just wasn't very warm to me ah i
think he just was like in the opener
yeah you know whatever yeah yeah wow
that's wild yeah you wouldn't go to the
bunny ranch no it's not my thing yeah
but but the woman um i would go to just
take a look
you know you want to scope it out that's
like going to the cheesecake factory and
just being like i just want to look at a
menu
look at the cakes man
let me look at that oreo look at that
all right i'm out of here great stopping
now it looks great but i'll feel
horrible after
well also the woman he was with was like
you're really funny i think that he
didn't like me oh well of course cause
he's like an old dude that'll do it a
little uh threatened
i mean he had no reason to be i'm sure i
had no shot but i think you know but i
think at the moment you know her just
saying that was enough for him to be
like
[ __ ] this guy yeah yeah yeah
i forgot why i brought it up hold on
prostitution vegas vegas oh vegas yeah
no bigger soul crush in vegas than when
you're like i'm at a bar playing
penny slots i'm drinking free gin and
tonics and some hot beautiful woman
sidles up next to you and it's like hey
i like the way you pull that crank and
i'm like well hell you know look at me
cleaning up
and then your eight friends are like
yeah what's going on with you and that
hooker you're like ah that's not a
hooker we're in love
yeah that's susie don't talk about her
like that russian and evie's have a
great joke russ has got a lot of great
jokes but i love the one he had about uh
you ever ever be like it's 300 and i'm
like oh what a coincidence i am also a
prostitute i'm 400
i will waive my fee if you're willing to
waive yours wow that's great that's
great
[Laughter]
wait thomas aguero had a very similar
job oh really he does oh no i can't
remember how it goes
you can do in vegas
you know you go up to a processor on the
street and you're like
you know
fifty dollars it's like more like five
hundred dollars and you're like bet
and you go back to the hotel room and
she's like show me the money and you're
like no you show me the money i'm a
prostitute too i'll just try to give you
a deal it's also yeah look every joke's
been done yeah what can you do oh boy
let them fight it out
both both hilarious comics obviously
yeah but that's the difference between
men and women right there it's a lady
will a hot lady will sit next to you
who's a prostitute
i don't think that works the other way
can a hot prostitute man or whatever
what is that a gigolo can he go up to a
woman and be like hey
and is the woman like this is awesome
yeah i'm probably not probably not
movies about it american gigolo true
true but i think he got they like call
him he comes over he massages their feet
or whatever
cinematic classics like deuce bigelow
which you know
are based on real life things yes yeah
that's a great documentary
but you know they made two of those
[ __ ] by the way the european jiggle
yeah yes exactly one of the worst movies
ever made really well at one point
there's a lady with a nose that looks
like a dick and she blows her nose and
he's like ah come shot you know
this [ __ ] jizz goes there it's so bad
but it's fun yeah i liked the version
when i was a kid but i was a kid same i
haven't seen it it's fun when
movies like that exist like we're
allowed to be this [ __ ] and silly
you know that's nice yeah it's good like
i grew up watching uh three amigos i
love that movie love three amigos that's
tropic thunder before tropic thunder
exactly yeah oh good point i never
thought about that that's a great flick
i saw tropic thunder in the theater
that's a great one great movie
yeah classic it's weird uh i mean by the
way shout out to john lovitz because i
just feel like he
every time he popped up in an old movie
it was just always solid always solid
yeah is he gay
i don't think so hmm
well should tell his voice
okay
jealous how does he say it
i mean dude john lovis was great high
school high yeah i loved that movie
classic i had the vhs me too classic
what do you got on a wreck
wreck oh man i don't know man i have so
many
i it's funny i was i was taking a walk
the other day i was feeling depressed
and then i took a walk
and walk is underrated i know it's a
norman wreck yeah i was kind of like i'm
listening to your ex this is important
to take walks because i told someone
feeling depressed and they were like
what's a nice day outside and i was like
oh yeah it's 5 p.m i should probably
take a walk that's not helping right but
uh
here's one here's one wreck i was
thinking of
and i this started during the pandemic
revisit your childhood revisit dumb [ __ ]
that makes you happy like i'll put it
this way oh okay the good part the good
part no no not the bad parts focus on
the good like take a movie that you
loved as a kid and sometimes you'll be
watching and be like there's a bad movie
but sometimes you'll be watching be like
yeah this is [ __ ] i'm laughing really
hard yeah like happy gilmore was on tv i
was like i'm laughing
my ass off and then billy madison was on
tv and i was like i'm laughing my ass
off yes and uh and it's just like
revisit movies that's my wreck revisit
movies you loved as a kid and sometimes
you'll be like aunt but a lot of the
time you'll be like yeah i was right
yeah yeah i i i'm with you i had one of
the great moments i was at a christmas
vacation or christmas dinner with a
bunch of my girl's family i was like at
her place in cape cod and it's all these
10 year olds running around 12 year olds
and i go we got to watch a movie we're
watching happy gilmore and they're like
what's that and i'm like that's a movie
from when i was a kid it's really funny
and they're like oh it's gonna be so
boring it's probably like you know
anything from the 90s they're like 90s
that's like the 50s for us
and i'm like it's good
10 minutes in they're howling laughing
they're dying the moms are all freaking
out because there's some some touchy
spots in it but they loved it and i
remember being like all right i was
right it's so good so good
just and dumb good like just nothing
pretentious about it just silly and yeah
yeah that's my wreck revisit something
fun from your childhood
i like it you're gonna feel good i like
it ferris bueller's mine amazing movie
amazing that was that was your go-to
comedy as a kid easily easily number one
i mean i loved animal house and
caddyshack and three amigos and beverly
hills cop yeah yeah what about bob
ghostbusters all that [ __ ] but uh
ferris bueller i felt like i wanted to
be him
yeah he was cool yeah it was it's it's
hard to be cool in a comedy and he was
cool yes
that's one bummer thing uh watching that
scorsese doc is all these every year
he's trying to win the academy award he
can't do it he can't do it but the
oscars looks so fun nicholson's got the
sunglasses on he probably did blow off a
hooker's ass on the green room you know
like in the department he just smacked
it everywhere yeah
which is what he won for uh scorsese
eventually but it was just fun it was
hollywood it was glitz it was glamor and
now it just feels like it feels so
tiptoey now like can we do this can we
do that eggshells eggshells everybody's
mad at us everybody's in trouble
twitter's pissed their instincts are
terrible yeah big problem is like
jim carrey put it perfectly like they
were they're like we're no longer the
cool club yeah you're not i mean it's
just the truth i mean you guys
you blew it you blew it you blew it i
mean like there was this like virtue
signaling holier-than-thou vibe they
have where it's like
no one wants to [ __ ] hear that [ __ ]
no no one wants to be told who to vote
for by an actor no one wants to be told
how to think by someone who reads lines
for a living yes
sing it be an entertainer like i agree i
think it's important like with comics
like guys like us like to remember to
just be [ __ ] funny because that's the
job that's how we got the job yeah right
we didn't get the job by being like
here's what you should uh here's how you
should vote in this next election you
know what i mean if you could make it
funny make it funny but like
when you're leading with that [ __ ] and
the oscars just seems like
like uh
the way they handled the chris rockwool
smith thing well yeah i mean first off
just like not immediately being like
[ __ ] you right exactly
and they got up their own ass and i
think the pandemic revealed how
worthless and untalented and interesting
they are like look dale j lewis is a
talented [ __ ] leonardo is a
talented guy but like these black and
white videos and the people like
needing attention again but now they
have no baby handlers they need handlers
yes chelsea handlers
so it just sucks cause you're like i'm
watching the oscars in the 90s i never
missed it i was like a little theater
queef you know i was like oh my god the
oscars are on oh man they're talking
about l.a confidential oh boy you know
whatever and now it's just like
they're just going which way the wind is
blowing and it's so obvious and
who cares about what they think i don't
care what bradley cooper thinks about
this event
you know or that event or that news
story like go act go kill it make some
good movies and move on there's a there
are people who have followings for their
views
and they none of them are actors right
yeah yeah good point you know we have
that already yeah yeah just we need to
but even those people kind of bore me
because sure they become predictable i
mean like there's people i follow on
twitter you know right-wing people
left-wing people
and
they just you just know what they're
gonna say on every news story yeah some
of them surprise you and we'll say
something funny but
there's people like when the the masks
you know no longer you have to wear
masks on airplanes and they're just like
you know i'm a good so now you'll have
you can't tweet about this for a second
this is all you've tweeted about for two
and a half years
his masks and covid
find something else to talk about yes
please we're done with covet enough yeah
yeah move on and i mean we're not done
people are still getting it but you know
what i mean but we're [ __ ] ready to
live yeah and but go go improve your own
life everybody's just like this is wrong
that's wrong that's bad but their life's
in shambles go fix that [ __ ] and then
come back to us with all your uh
opinions about
the world and society
yeah i'm with you though i used to watch
the oscars like in the 90s and i i just
thought nicholson was the coolest oh the
best because i grew up on those movies
you know like uh i mean i remember
seeing one floor of the cuckoo's nest i
was like that's [ __ ] i was like blown
away that that was a movie i know that
was like i was like this dude is like i
relate to this guy he's like pestering i
know it's like also a bigger
anti-authority type thing where she's
you just hate her sure
nurse ratchet but
you know then you get older and you're
like yeah probably wasn't a fun gig for
her either even though i even though i
hated her yeah but
uh
but how do you not identify especially
like young aspiring comics like us you
know maybe we didn't know we wanted to
be that yet you look at that and you're
like nicholson's like he's [ __ ] funny
and he's cool
and he's uh yeah it's the best it's the
best old movies classics are there's
nothing better man but what's crazy with
this score and i keep bringing back the
scorsese doc but it hit home it's like
he's this avant-garde italian kid from
the village he's weird he's making these
crazy movies with blood and guts and
like he made a jake lamotta movie
everybody's like who the [ __ ] jake
lamotta you know he makes these weird
choices and in black and white he did it
yeah and nobody would give him love and
uh he felt like he couldn't break
through and a lot of bombs a lot of
failures a lot of movies went way under
uh like you know he spent 20 million to
make it but they made 3 million at the
box of it the producers hate them the
investors are furious and he just you
know became a cokehead and whatever but
like he kept going and then he made
something he made after hours and that
did okay and then he made an underrated
movie underrated but yeah he makes they
had the aviator and everyone's like damn
and so we focus so it's just like comedy
where we focus so much on what they're
saying and not what the point is you
know they're like this movie is so
violent cut it out you're like i know
but look how it touches on the italian
lifestyle or whatever you know and they
would miss all that because they just
thought he was this coke head
like a scary movie guy or not scary but
like they would just focus on the the
violence instead of focusing on this
brilliant filmmaker it's the same people
in the comedy crowd who are like you
said the word rape i'm like yeah but the
rest of the joke is how it's bad i know
you know it's funny you know uh
he's stuck in the pocket though and you
build a follow and you just keep making
great [ __ ] yeah but i i it makes a lot
of sense why i mean he was then the
criticism is crazy they'll be like
casino it's just goodfellas light and
you're like i know but it's still a
great movie it's still fun goodfellas
light is better than
95 of the movies this year good point so
it's worth watching because there's a
lot of times where he's just down and
out and he's like i can't go on i can't
keep making this [ __ ] it's too hard i
pour my heart onto these movies and they
trash them nobody goes to see them and
you see de niro like you got to get back
in there man come on this is on youtube
it's on youtube yeah but it's it's dense
well you know the thing about it too is
like when you make as many movies when
you're as prolific as he is you're gonna
kind of hit similar territory it's
unavoidable i mean look at what woody
allen's as prolific as any filmmaker
ever and there's a lot of like okay
you're like oh another movie with
cheating and murder it's like yeah
you're gonna hit the same [ __ ] sometimes
yeah but
that doesn't mean that it's still not
good or you find a different way in i
mean same with stand-up we will retread
similar grounds sometimes in a special
but that doesn't mean we can't find a
new a new way in right exactly and you
know when the industry's not [ __ ]
with you but all these comics are isn't
that that's such a flattering thing
that's what he had like all these all
these actors even though his movies were
bombing like bringing out the dead
bombed he lost a lot of money on that
yeah you haven't even seen it is it good
it's all right it's it's a little much i
didn't love it but
but he's so great great it's still great
great people are going to miss sometimes
too yeah exactly and so a lot of actors
and actresses were like i want to work
with scorsese holy [ __ ]
so you got to remember that even when
you're when we're having trouble
struggling we can't get a an hour we
can't do this we can't do that
the comics still look up to you and
that's what you got to remember
so uh really interesting stuff
really cool i love any biopic i'm
obsessed with artists and all that [ __ ]
so i'm watching the tarantino one next
you know what's interesting too is a
movie like taxi driver is so
i feel like so many people could like
that movie for different reasons
yeah i mean like there's a lot of ways
to read into a movie like that totally i
feel like you could be dumb as [ __ ] and
love that movie you could also be like
an intellectual and love that movie yeah
there's so many i mean there's so much
to it
uh i agree i always go back to the
simpsons it's smart people like it and
dumb people like it it's a it's a
brilliant show what's your favorite
what's your number one for square give
me your top five oh
this is tough right wow that's a good
thing you have to do an order but just
give me the five best
i think raging bull is up there i think
taxi drivers got to be in there
obviously goodfellas i would put casino
in and then i i might go uh
[Music]
uh
i love cape fear i love wolf of wall
street i love uh love after hours
i love the color of money i watched 800
times but like kundun that one no one
saw that he went to china and all this
[ __ ] and george harrison dock was good
that was great so yeah he's got a ton of
good ones so wait so what's your five
uh taxi driver raging bull goodfellas
uh
casino and what uh
may it's i don't know color money after
hours cape fear i i like wolf of wall
street before those trees are good stuff
like gangs in new york as well gangs in
new york is good it's tough oh do you
have a five for it's going to be i'm
just gonna say like gangs in new york is
definitely it has to be up there um yeah
aviator is pretty awesome i think yeah
maybe it is well done especially when
you like think about like the um
like the backstory of that guy like how
he just became this crazy hermit and
whatever yeah like sad sad life
there was a story wasn't there that guy
in the pockets malcolm bladwell the guy
who did the fake interview with uh
what's his name uh howard hughes howard
hughes by the way
you look a little howard hughes-ish i do
have you seen howard hughes no i don't
think he's like a he's got a mustache so
that's gonna throw it off but you got
he's got a morel in him i don't think he
kind of hold on pull him up he looks
like iron man's dad in those movies
a little bit come on look at the eyes
he's a handsome guy by the way
yeah he was a giant playboy like he was
like the hugh hefner of his time before
he became all reclusive yeah i don't
think i look like him all right i'll
take it mark look at that look that's a
good looking guy there yeah that's right
that's why i don't think i look like him
but uh straight
he was the elon musk of his day look at
that that's merrill like that when you
old you're gonna look like that picture
okay
holy [ __ ] yeah a little bit in that one
he's a tall thin man as well
the thin man one of my favorite books oh
yeah great book
daschle hammett that's a wreck if you've
never read he was a pinkerton he was a
he was a detective in his day before he
wrote those books uh the thin man
witty as hell pinkerton what is that
though it's communism it's like a
detective oh oh and you know he uh
he really solved cases and it's like
about this it's the coolest setup for a
thing where it's uh the wife nicki nor
charles and the wife is uh she comes
she's rich and he's a retired cop so he
just is like a rich retired cop so he's
got the muscle and the resources it's
just a perfect setup and they're both
super witty it's it's great stuff okay
but uh yeah they made a movie the
movie's supposed to be good too i never
saw the movie but uh
what we talk oh let me give you my five
please
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimel
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous but
if they flake i'm stuck with a whole
bill and then i discovered fandible
fanable has tickets to everything
there's no fees the price you see is the
price you pay that's i mean that's
pretty big yeah not only those prices
transparent but they're almost always
lower than anywhere else i look and for
any hot ticket like coachella a laker
game or dave chappelle fanimal is always
the cheapest option nobody gives nobody
goes to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimel although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bails are weird if i come alone
i said no dude enjoy yourself yeah and
you know what the guy made new friends
at the show they tweeted me afterwards i
sat with these guys and they were
tweeting me too so you end up having a
great time no matter what
um
fanimal's patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them how mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20
of credit
20 of credit towards your first purchase
we drink on this show check out fanimal
and experience more support the show and
get 20 off your first purchase with the
code drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot com get on we might be drunk as
excited to welcome our new sponsor
diet smoke most of us have had a i don't
think this edible is working moment then
10 minutes later you're on the couch and
you can't remember the word cat i've
been there edibles can hit you when you
least expect it and their dosage can be
very uncertain that's why when we need
the perfect medium high we hit our
friends at diet smoke for the delicious
delta 8 thc gummies
each gummy is infused with 10 milligrams
of delta 8 thc derived from american
grown health hemp delta 8 is simply a
slightly less potent thc the high you
get with diet smoke is somewhere between
the chilledness the cbd and that classic
stone feeling you get with regular weed
plus diet smoke comes in two delicious
favorite flavors blue raspberry and
watermelon i've been taking this stuff
to go to bed you know me i can't get
high i go inward i hug my knees i think
of my dad i cry
this stuff is top notch it's just what i
need it's like having a light beer yeah
you heard her dad does the same thing he
gets on his knees he thinks of you he
cries it's
this stuff right here that's how i got
in this mess
oh geez it's legal in most states and
non-prescription just check diet smokes
website to see if they ship to your
state also their gummies are low in
sugar fat free and delish so when cbd
isn't enough and traditional thc is too
much enjoy the smooth buzz of diet smoke
that's dietsmoke.com use promotional
code drunk for 20 off your order that's
dietsmoke.com promo code drunk 20 off as
a special offer diet smokes coupon code
can be used on every order
so give it a shot come back say like
yeah i'm doing this again 20 off again
diet smokes delta 8 thc gummies are not
for use or sale to people under the age
of 21 please use responsibly diet smoke
isn't light
it's just red
good fellas
taxi driver
and then the part is so much fun the
part is definitely in mine i love it
if we're talking rewatch value that's
number one for me yeah it's the funniest
ah it is fun it's [ __ ] old baldwin's
hilarious wahlberg's hilarious
nicholson's hilarious right right leo
and damon are great it's a great it's a
great movie yeah it got people were like
it's overrated because it's it's over
the top but it's way over the top but
it's who gives a [ __ ] it's fun as hell
fun if that's on tv and you don't finish
it you're [ __ ] lying
theater twice yeah same i loved it uh i
think i might have to put after hours in
mine just because i love it
it's hard to not put comedy in there too
i know which also bombed but i might go
i mean dude wolf of wall street's so
good it's so good hard enough to put
wolf of wall street in there i know i
know the jonah hill stories are great
that's why these docks are so cool
because they're so they get behind like
matt damon had to audition for the party
he's like you gotta get me in there i'm
a boston guy and he was like i don't
know i don't know and yeah he killed it
he killed it yeah by the way the the
departed there's an x in every scene
where people die
the kid getting groceries in the
beginning when john when uh matt damon
has groceries at the end it's the same
contents in the grocery bag showing that
he was with jack nilsson i mean there's
so many easter eggs that they cover
everything i'm sure
yeah it's hard not to put raging bull in
there though
i love shutter island dude that was a
big hit for him that's a great movie i
never watched it oh it's great it's a
remember the beach
pretty good pretty good leo that made
that apparently
huge like tourism thing and then like a
huge uh
like uh like you know crime against the
tourist thing and then a huge
conservation thing so it had this like
like kind of waterfall interesting
that was bad when movies would could
make a splash
like we used to sit around and talk
about certain movies that came out and
what they did and they had an effect on
the country
i feel like that doesn't happen anymore
you know what i loved is uh
i mean any school i loved when he just
trashed marvel movies yeah i did too he
got a lot of [ __ ] for that because i
also like do i like some of those marvel
movies sure but enough man i know like
it's like i get it like it's a business
and you're all these are making bank but
like yeah you people were like we're
shocked you're shocked that one of the
greatest artists of our [ __ ] time
doesn't love theme park ride movies i
know like it was on it was on point i
thought i thought i agree i agree i love
uh
that's what i hate about these industry
queefs sorry to cut you off is they they
all go
i love scorsese i love kubrick i love uh
coppola and then they go but we gotta
get this uh hawkeye movie made and
you're like hawkeye like it's gonna sell
it's the same with these comedy industry
people they go i love carlin and prior
but
i don't know you i don't know whatever
we're booking
carrot top and you're like what but come
on
yeah i thought you loved uh irreverent
or original stuff they don't they don't
they're con men they're they're business
people they want to make money which i
get but don't tell me you love god don't
try and be a [ __ ] con artist yeah
exactly just live your life as a [ __ ]
soul-crushing scumbag don't pretend to
be in the heart
right i'm totally with you we get that
all the time we're huge fans really
because it's the first time i've heard
from you in 17 years
uh i know they're like look we love your
work we'll never make anything with you
we just want you to know that we like it
exactly so you can see you leave
confused i'm like oh that makes sense
that's cool
um yeah way to lead me on and then
i like uh
i like that he did that i thought it was
really cool
yeah whoo that squish ac [ __ ] on the oh
too yeah i mean it's like
you know
he he makes art house movies yeah just
happen to be it's like hitchcock where
they're like yeah some of them cat sean
but these are like this guy's got the
soul of an art house filmmaker totally
totally yeah it's all about cinema yeah
it's all about his his hero is a
ileon kazan because
he's
named names he named names which is bad
[ __ ] he got an award at the uh oscars
they cover all this and yeah a couple
people wouldn't applaud yeah [ __ ] him
dude he named names yeah bad dude but i
will say good movies i will say uh
what's the one to do with on the
waterfront that's a top 10 movie ever
yeah
it's hard to argue i mean it's that's a
brilliant movie brilliant movie i mean
the guy was a beast but he was and he
did uh
he did the james d movies wow he did um
look up ilya kazam movies he did [ __ ]
uh
the tennessee williams play street car
he did he did that yeah wow
stella
that's a great [ __ ] movie yeah look
at this movie
i mean the guy changed the game he was
huge
wow but yeah he uh he outed a bunch dude
he did communist what else did he do he
did something else really big
is he a holocaust uh
uh no you think that hillary was l i
think oh night good book yeah good book
hard reading yeah i've acquired reading
in my class it was what else yeah whoa
yeah i think most schools would force
you to read that what
we're missing something like eli kazan
there's something that we're really well
we got uh we got some pretty big ones we
got
let's see
pinky that's awkward
a face in the crowd
that's the one dude there you go i don't
know that one oh dude
watch that [ __ ] all right that's my
wreck for this week a face in the crowd
i think it's on criterion
it's uh andy griffith it's like a con
man who rises the ranks it's incredible
oh really he holds up so much comedian
andy griffith dude it's incredible all
right haley kazan he named names but he
made great and also if you haven't seen
on the waterfront [ __ ] that's a top
10 movie ever dude yeah that's a
phenomenal that's uh
brando was hot i wanted to be a
contender yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] brando
dude he was hot so hot those lips what a
man yeah a man with lips
he's got some dsls on he does he was hot
look at him dude wow he's pretty and
tough at the same time which is rare
that movie [ __ ] rules great script do
we have a brando now i would throw it to
tom hardy
really well i think he's got lips he
does have lips and he's tough he's tough
and i think he's a good actor he is good
i wouldn't say he's brando brando's like
this legendary level yeah i know tom
hardy's good but we have daniel day
lewis but he's not high how about
christian bale oh
he's got range
yeah yeah bale is good
look at the bale has done so much [ __ ]
although he did this he did a superhero
movie does that hurt
well he was batman he's great as bruce
wayne yeah i would give him
batman yeah you guys seen uh him i'm
hurting bronson brian no is that girl
dude
pinchot bronson is amazing
charles bronson was like an action man
right yeah but he's but in real life he
was actually the most dangerous criminal
in the uk oh and he would just
fight everybody and uh tom hardy this
movie this is like basically like a
biped about him and uh he
interviewed bro he met with him and
bronson
liked him so much he somehow shaved off
his iconic mustache
and sent it to tom hardy to like wear
for the wow
because he was so impressed weird wow
he's like a legit maniac but
dude this movie's amazing i'll watch
that all right no he is awesome he's a
great actor yeah he's good and i think
he's the highest paid actor without
speaking
he doesn't speak in mad max barely
speaking dunkirk and there's another
movie he has like no lines in but damn i
forgot he was a mad max oh yeah he's a
good dick
oh another hog we put him on the wall
about that that's a good gig no speaking
roles but highest paid yeah but oh yeah
i'm sure a good dick too that's how you
get those no speaking roles he's great
yeah i like i don't know it's probably
it's probably him maybe we don't have
these big big
brandos and carrie grants and uh what's
his name that you said earlier clooney's
cary grant oh that's right what about
bogart no bogart we don't have a bogart
you can't have a bogey was once in a
lifetime man wow
okay and i mean so is kerry grant but i
do see like a little clooney in that i
see that no one's like bogart really we
can't find one guy give me someone i'm
thinking here well bogart was tough he
was soft-spoken or or stoic yeah
he was tortured but still a gentleman
yeah somehow yeah he's tough
maybe i'll go with uh chaz bono
he's looking at you mom i was gonna say
hugh jackman hugh jackman
he's great but he's so different he's
like a song and he's like a dick powell
he's like a song and dance yeah he's
australian too yeah no it's gotta be an
american dude gotta be you s
hey that's nothing but these old there's
no bogey no i guess there's no we need a
bogey thing on this wall dude yeah we
should get a bogey get a bogey in here
no bogey
old school bogey come on also by the way
where's the name humphrey i've never
been a humphrey in my life it's a good
name you think yeah yeah humphrey awful
it's not great but he was cool he was
oh guard
yeah there's no humphreys anymore we
let's do news stories man
oh we gotta we gotta we're pushing it
here new study shows mushrooms
communicate with each other using a
vocabulary of 50 words wow
it's like a like a special needs kid
that's pretty good or a guy from the
midwest
[Laughter]
the strong silent type mushrooms yeah
they they mushrooms talk using
electrical impulses that spike when
fungi
come into contact with food sources or
potential dangers
okay oh i never got with the the plants
talk because they can't go anywhere
they're stuck they're like in them in
the same spot so oh there's guy coming
this is a lawn mower is on the way
you're like all right well i'm here
anyway they are like vegetables it's
like terry shively yeah i think she
moved a finger or something exactly
i never got that i do love those um what
do you call it when you speed up the
camera and they show the mushroom
growing
what is that called it's like hyper
something like time lapse time lapse
thank you
yeah mushrooms are badass they're kind
of living then yeah they i mean they are
living they're living they're my
favorite drug too mushrooms oh yeah
easily
i like them fungus is living
so that means you can that means you can
name your stds
um
you're a big mushroom guy i like him i
try i do him like three times a year but
you micro or you or what no i eat the
real troom you go hard yeah i don't [ __ ]
with the pills and i don't know what's
in that [ __ ] so i just cap stem cap stem
oh it tastes bad that tastes horrible
but you get over it you get through it
you're gonna we're gonna do it one day
one day all right peanut butter
peanut butter is good
hey see there it is time lapse that's
pretty cool time lapse is so crazy
wow he's making them in a box there they
go oh that's pretty cool it's where we
can eat mushrooms on a pizza
and they are a drug there's so many
different variations of mushroom it's
like people that's true
wow look at that
oh my god look at that
very exciting
time it's fascinating that's cool
look at that all right well this one's
freaked me out because of like the fact
that they do have an intelligence to
them like it weirs me out like cutting
them because i know that they've been
talking to each other like we just
learned like how long before vegans are
like no eating no eating
dude i've been saying that for years
good question
because they talk when we find out that
like you know they can feel pain just
like you know cows and everything like
that what are they gonna eat like that's
it exactly damn that'll be the next
pixar movie they're just mushrooms who
can't move they're like how bad
wow
i like the other different personalities
like
portobello
porcini
you're getting ripped from your stem but
you just can't do anything you're like
dad
daddy yeah yeah
90 day fiance star stephanie motto ended
up hospitalized after eating too many
beans to sell food oh
classic this is wait too many beans made
you fart the magical fruit that makes
you toot
stephanie motto sold her jarred
flatulence
uh flatulence for one thousand dollars a
piece jesus and made over 200 grand in
her two-month venture while
subsisting on a diet of yogurt eggs and
beans this is horrible horrible and
ended up in the hospital wow when she
thought she was having a heart attack
maybe you had an attack of the
conscience because this is disgusting
well this is clearly gaslighting
all right
but yeah this is crazy this is this is
why the terrorists hate us because we're
making 200 grand a month
or in two months selling farts in a jar
she's the fartrepreneur
this is yeah this is you're right i mean
this is disgusting yeah yeah but i guess
if people are paying for it nobody's
getting hurt except for her
she's in the hospital yeah no you're
right i mean i can't be a hypocrite it's
what i said earlier in the show right
about about prozzie's or sex workers or
whatever right but their body but at the
same time it's like what is wrong with
people i can always judge people for
being like farts in a like i understand
someone paying for sex that's like
you're lonely whatever paying for a fart
in a jar like this many people are into
this
[Music]
it's crazy i know i'm with you but she's
attractive obviously look at that but
it just shows how what we'll do if she
was if she looked like rosie o'donnell i
don't know if people would be buying it
i think the hotness goes a long way i
know but i just can't imagine like i
just opened it and be like
worth it
[Laughter]
that was worth uh
all those
good point how do we know i need a grade
a like a usda uh state let me get a
chipotle worker and [ __ ] he worked a
12-hour shift she is attractive but like
the fact that she does that is a
deal-breaker i think oh yeah definitely
hard to date someone if you walk in the
room you're like what are you doing
she's like i'm working
i'm working on my job when you back
yeah i wonder if there's a guy out there
who bought like 10 of them and he's like
hold on
the oaky a little fruity okay oh this
one's a heavy day okay this is a little
uh his wife walks in he's like you blew
our life savings
on her farts i'm working it's a fine
vintage you know yeah then you're with
her one night and she farts and you're
like what are you doing
that's our 401k right there
what's this
she's oh there's another lady selling
farts this girl sells her bath water
whoa you see this is female privilege
well no guy is selling his bath water no
nobody wants to buy this from a dude
nobody wants uh
and actually i do have a shout out
we will fart in those we might be drunk
glasses if you'd like yeah yeah there
are 4 000 a pop and uh paul giamatti is
an amazing actor he sells his bath
daughter he's going to get arrested
this gal gamer gal is uh killing it on
the bathwater
damn
what else we got now that's wild what a
world you wanna do this one georgia
woman was charged with faking a
pregnancy to get paid time
off huh robin folsom's colleagues became
suspicious when they noticed her bump
was askew
and she sent them inconsistent photos of
her fake children holy
hats off to this uh this con artist here
holy [ __ ] that's a tough lie to keep up
i know
again female privilege yes we don't get
to do that [ __ ] good point i get a bump
they don't say do you need time off they
go you look gross
get your [ __ ] together
yeah i did a bump in the uh the the
break room and i got fired so what the
hell
pandas do this apparently they fake
pregnancy they uh because it's so hard
for them to get pregnant they get
special treatment when they do get
pregnant and they learn that so they
fake like signs of pregnancy to get like
more forces that's pretty clever well
that's just pandering all right i'll see
you all in hell
but uh that's so embarrassing to get
busted doing that yeah like they're like
did you just lie about being pregnant
she's like yeah i don't
man yeah that's bad that is bad that's a
bad lie to be caught in
you're she's a piece of [ __ ] but i i'm
impressed i'm impressed with the
the um the fact that she got fake
children
i know that's what i love about it thea
what's the word she committed she
committed to the lie she should be
committed she should yes nancy shouldn't
have children
isn't that crazy about anybody can have
kids a pedophile can have children yeah
that's wild he probably won't though if
he goes young enough
true pedo jokes but if he can have one
else he's getting high on his own supply
archaeologists believe they've
discovered the tomb of santa claus
rape santa
a team at satan nicholas tomb of sam
turkey kids we found his corpse do you
want to see
he's not going to make it to the chimney
this year
had a coffin
in turkey they found an intriguing
shrine beneath the floors previously
unseen due to the tiled floors intricate
mosaic
all right they found they found a bunch
of reindeer skeletons dude he was in the
reindeer fighting uh
santa was mean
this is so weird
crazy
what the hell or oh is this the tomb
whoa oh
jeez i guess you couldn't have been that
fat look at that small yeah well that
was probably fat back then this is
santa's just like [ __ ] bezos yes he's
got people working for with no pay bad
uh bad work environment how do you get
your presents on time i treat elves
horribly
that's how i do it yeah you're right
um i think this is the next national
treasure movie actually whoa that's kind
of cool though like look at that it's
kind of beautiful oh that's something
that can be that old and right
indiana jonesy
okay what else
what do you got personal trainer dies
after consuming a workout drink with as
much caffeine as 200 cups of coffee
jesus i'll tell you man you're on your
way there fatty
the way you put down those cups of
folgers i'm worried about i love coffee
i do too but that's the thing is i like
i like coffee so this is why this will
never happen to me
because this this is like rockstar
energy type energy like this is a dude
where you're just like remember uh we
knew that guy uh who ran that club in
scottsdale yes and he had a stroke
because he he did a bunch of coke and
did uh and drank like 14 red bulls whoa
and you're like yeah dude that'll do it
yes you're not supposed to mix coke with
14 red bulls
you should know that holy hell
when weighing his caffeine powder caused
him to go in a cardiac arrest
that sucks man yeah but also 200 cups
you're [ __ ] stupid enough's enough
exactly
like don't you have bad anxiety around i
don't know 50 cups of coffee yeah right
doesn't it start to hit you or you're
like uh also uh you know what's bad for
you is uh 97 bags of cocaine
you should not you should not do that
and i get coffee headaches if i don't
have a cup that day so imagine what this
guy's going through that
[ __ ] uh withdrawal has got to be
tough
i do get bad headaches yeah i need it
when you wake up i mean it's like it's
cliche and like you turn into that
annoying dude in the office where you're
just like i'm don't talk to me till i've
had my coffee but like holy [ __ ] are we
cranky you know what's [ __ ] up this is
how crazy the brain is and this this is
the bloody mary's kicking in but i'll
have those coffee headaches and if i
make a coffee i can sniff it the
headache will go away because your brain
thinks like oh he's about to drink it
that's how [ __ ] up the brain is oh
exactly you have the first sip you feel
better and it hasn't hit you yet i know
you feel exactly i mean the second you
have that sip it's like it's gonna be
okay yes same with the booze let's be
honest when you're really hung over and
you
you hit that high life at the home at
home at 10 a.m you feel a little better
this is this drink is incredible i know
i want another one but i'm trying to
hang back yeah i mean we got to do a
patreon we got to do yeah you got to
work tonight yeah all right we we should
wrap this up yeah well we got two more
news two more okay or is this it this
might be it a woman a wisconsin woman
allegedly murdered her lover after a
meth fueled sex game that just
dismembered his corpse holy then
dismembered holy [ __ ]
yeah everyone in this is in green bay i
read about this everyone in green bay
they talk about being uh cheese heads
they're actually meth heads
they should have to wear meth on their
heads or those packer games yes taylor
shabbas
[Music]
the business failure business your
business
told police they would have fun
trying to find all of her lovers limbs
and organs wow
that's the worst hide and seek game of
all time really gross brothers she looks
good actually jesus look at that yeah
would you i would not too shabby would
you let her cut you up into little
pieces maybe maybe if i was having a bad
enough day why the hell not she's got
the hoop earrings i always say you can
tell how crazy a woman is by the size of
her hoops that's where this comes from
old joke i remember when you pitched
that to me i think it was 12 years ago
that was like 2009 norman stuck with me
never left it i never put it on an act
or an album but it's fun it's in the
head it's a good silly one very
wisconsin couple there that poor guy i
am head in a bucket holy [ __ ] sounds
like a punk band hit that are you ready
for a head in a bucket
boom boom
all right well there you go should we do
we have time for a bit or should we
should we save uh i think
what should we do how are we doing i
think we got time for a bit well what
time is our guest coming on the next
show
let me check i forgot oh we should we
don't have time okay damn that's all
right all right well you guys are the
best see norman on the road yeah we're
gonna be brother i mean uh well that's
over according to the the day this comes
out laughing up and poughkeepsie doing a
one-nighter stand up live in huntsville
alabama
pantages theater in minneapolis i love
minneapolis chicago at the vic cleveland
at the agora
uh bon secours wellness arena that
should oh that's with bert doing some
gigs with bert on the full
throttle [ __ ] totally wasted i can't
remember
uh dragway in tennessee lawrenceville
georgia brandon missouri irvine
california come on out to the improv
that's a big room we need you there and
uh red bank new jersey
all kinds of houston improv all kinds of
good stuff san antonio laugh out loud
come on out say hello
i'm in houston that month too yeah
toronto
providence uh chicago tampa cleveland
uh buffalo
yeah yeah uh houston west palm
san jose i'm all over that [ __ ]
samwell.com we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com we might be drunkpod.com for
merch uh we might yeah email us rex
peeves all that [ __ ] the patreon sign up
we love you thanks for listening beer
drew we love you matt peters we love you
killed it got that studios we're gonna
be moving soon
so uh we'll get you the new address send
us your gifts your wrecks your queefs
your notes whatever you got thank you
appreciate
[Music]
you know the it
close
i've had a little too much burping and
norman's talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
poke and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we
might be
true
[Music]